[Musique]
à 80 ans avec 300 romans à son actif
barbara cartland est la reine
incontestée du roman d'amour
j'écris sur l'amour des troubadours
roméo et juliette
héloïse et abélard l'amour vrai que tout
le monde recherche et que si peu de gens
trouvent
je pense que toutes les femmes et
surtout vous les françaises savent très
bien qu'elles peuvent régner à partir de
la chambre à coucher
si elles sont réellement intelligente
elle laisse l'homme croit qu'il est seul
à tout décider
les femmes ont toujours eu une grande
place dans l'histoire du monde en
restant des femmes mais maintenant voilà
qu'elle se prenne pour des hommes et
qu'ils veulent ce dôme domaine où en ce
domaine
avez-vous je n'ai rencontré les hommes
que vous décrivez dans vos livres
ça m'est arrivé mais bien entendu mes
personnages sont des mélanges est mon
héros est l'homme idéal mais je suis
toujours à la recherche d'un beau
ténébreux durée un beau ténébreux du ray